DAVID JORDAN: Hello, and
welcome back to recitation.
I'd like to work on a
problem with you, which
is to compute the volume
of a parallelepiped using 3
by 3 determinants.
So here we've got the
parallelepiped drawn.
It has, one of its vertices
is at the origin, (0, 0, 0),
and the other three
edges are given to us
with these coordinates here.
So why don't you take some
time to work out this problem,
pause the video, and check
back with me and I'll show you
how I solved it.
OK, welcome back.
Let's get started.
So the first thing
that we need to do
is we need to remember
that computing
volumes of parallelepipeds is
the same thing as computing 3
by 3 determinants.
So the volume is just equal
to the determinant, which
is built out of the vectors,
the row vectors determining
the edges.
So we have-- well,
that's almost true.
This determinant will be either
a positive or negative number
and we always want to
take the positive number.
So I'm going to write
plus or minus here,
and we'll have to
remember at the end
that we want a positive number.
So we can compute
this determinant
using Laplace expansion as
we did in the last video.
So for Laplace
expansion, we take
the-- we can do Laplace
expansion on the first row.
And that will again be nice,
because this 0 here will
make our computation simpler.
And so, remember what we do
is we take the first entry
in the row, and then we need
to multiply by the minor
that we get by covering up
that row and that column.
So we have this little
2 by 2 determinant,
which looks like minus 1.
And now we need to
subtract the next entry
in the row times its
minor, which is now
this matrix [1, 1; 0, 1].
So taking that determinant,
we get 1 minus 0.
So altogether, we get 1.
So what that tells us is that
our determinant is minus 4.
But then that tells us
that our volume is plus 4.
And I'll leave it at that.